字幕: Mizuho WATANABE
校正: Kyohei Kawada
（拍手）
はい では みなさん
改めまして こんにちは
（こんにちは）
緊張が ほぐれました
今から みなさんに 時間を借りて
お話を 聞いてもらいます
それは 「思うは招く」 っちゅう お話です
僕の母さんが 中学生のときに
教えてくれた言葉です
思ったら そうなるよ って意味です
思い続けるって 大事です
僕は 今日のお話で
みなさんの中から 仲間が見つかったら
いいや と思ってしますので
ぜひね 仲間になってほしいです
僕は 今から47年前に生まれました
植松 努って いいます
僕は 今 北海道の真ん中へんにある
赤平っていう町で
生まれて初めて 会社を経営しています
僕たちは そこで 本当は
リサイクルに使われる
マグネットっていう 機械をつくっています
でも そのかたわらで ロケットをつくります
僕たちは 宇宙開発ができて
丸ごとロケットをつくれて
打ち上げできるようになって
そして 人工衛星も
丸ごと 飛ばせるようになって
そして 世界で３つしかない
日本には僕の会社にしかない
宇宙と同じ 無重力状態をつくる
実験装置も 持っています
どれも 売っていないから
買うことができません
でも 自分たちでがんばって つくりました
でも 僕にとって 宇宙開発は
僕の夢じゃないんです
僕にとって 宇宙開発は
僕の 手段にすぎません
僕は 今から47年前に生まれました
小さかった僕に ばあちゃんが
大事なことを 教えてくれました
僕のばあちゃんは
北海道の北にある 樺太という島で
昔から 自動車の会社をやっていて
がんばって働いて お金を貯めて
豊かに暮らしたそうです
でも 樺太は 1945年
突然 ソビエト軍が攻めてきて
たくさんの人が 殺されて
ばあちゃんは 自分が貯金したお金が
全部 紙くずになったことを 知ったそうです
だから ばあちゃんは
小さい僕に 教えてくれました
お金は 値打ちが変わってしまうもんだよ
だから くだらない
お金があったら 貯金なんかしないで
本を買いなさい
頭に入れなさい
それは 誰にもとられないし
新しいことを 生み出すんだよ
と 教えてくれました
だから僕は
本屋が大好きな子どもになりました
また 僕には
大好きな じいちゃんがいました
おっきくて 優しい じいちゃんです
僕とじいちゃんとの 一番の思い出は
アポロの月着陸です
一緒に テレビ 見ました
僕が覚えてるのは
じいちゃんが 見たこともないほど
喜んでいる姿です
ほら見れ～ ほら見れ～ って
人が 月へ行ったぞ って
お前も 月行けるぞって 喜んでるんです
僕は そんな喜んでる じいちゃん
見たことなかったです
だから 僕は その笑顔が
もっかい 見たかったです
だから 本屋に行ったら 僕は
飛行機 ロケットの本を 手に取ったんです
そしたら じいちゃんは でっかい手で
僕の頭を なぜてくれるんです
ほめてくれるんです
僕は きっと じいちゃんの笑顔が見たくって
きっと 飛行機 ロケットが
好きになっちゃたんだろうって 思います
僕はそのあとも
いろんな 素晴らしい本に 出会います
そして 中学生になった頃には
僕の夢というものは
飛行機や ロケットの仕事を
することに なっていました
自分なりに 一生懸命 勉強していました
でも 中学校の先生が
僕に 教えてくれました
そんな 夢みたいなことを 言ってないで
テスト勉強をしなさいと 言われました
確かに僕は
飛行機 ロケットの勉強はしたけど
学校の勉強は ほったらかしだったんです
なんにも していませんでした
そして 先生は さらに教えてくれます
そもそも 宇宙なんちゅうものは
よほど頭が良くないと 無理だ
すごく お金がかかるんだぞ
だからそれは 別世界の話だ
お前なんかに できるわけがないって
教えてくれました
僕は とっても悲しくなりました
そして 考えたんです
夢って なんだろう？ って
できそうな夢しか
見ちゃダメなんでしょうか？
でも できるかできないかは
いったい誰が 決めるんだろうって
思いました
やってみなきゃ わかんないはずなのに
やったこともない人が決めるのは
変じゃないのかなと 思いました
そして僕は
今 できないことを 追いかけることが
夢っていうんじゃないのかなって
思ったんです
ところが そうじゃないみたいです
なぜならば 僕は
いろんな大人に 脅されたんです
ちゃんと 勉強をしなければ
いい学校に行けなくて
いい会社に入れなくて 大変だよって
僕は あんまり成績 良くないです
だから 心配になって 質問をしました
いい会社って なんだろう？ って
そしたら 大人が 教えてくれました
安定していて 楽をして お金をもらえるのが
いい会社だと 言われました
僕は 納得できませんでした
なぜならば 勉強すればするほど
能力が 身につくはずです
ところが せっかく身につけた その能力を
なるべく使わないで 楽をするために
勉強するんだって 言われたんです
そんなら 勉強しなくていいんじゃないの？
と 思ってしまったんです
でも お金があると いいことが
いっぱいあるかもしれません
たとえば この
（笑）
すっごい車！
（拍手）
僕んじゃないです
僕んじゃないです これは
（笑）
この車が 手に入るのは
金持ちだからでしょうか？
全然 違いますね？
この車が手に入るのは
お金で 買うことができるのは
どっかで 誰かが がんばって
つくっているからなんです
もっといいものをつくろうと思って
一生懸命研究して
努力している人たちがいるから
売ってもらえてるから
買うことができてるだけの話なんです
実は お金って たいしたこと ないんです
だって お金が必要な夢とか
お金がないと 無理だぁ！っていう夢
それは 実は 誰かがしてくれる
サービスに すぎないんです
これを 待ってるだけの 話なんです
そして 自分が できなければできないほど
してもらうしかありません
ってことは 生きてくために どんどん
お金が かかってしまう ということなんです
ところが 自分ができると
できることが あればあるほど
それは してあげられるから
仕事になるかもしれない
っちゅうことなんです
ってことは 人間が生きてく上で
大事なことは
できなかったことが
できるようになること なのかもしれません
それが もしかしたら 人間にとって
素晴らしいことかもしれません
だとしたら 僕が考えた
今 できないことを 追いかけるのが
夢 なんじゃないの？
っていうのは
正しいのかもしれないんです
ところが 僕は一生懸命
自分の大好きなことを 追いかけたんです
でも それは まわりの人に
理解されなくなりました
友達からも 先生からも
そして 親からも
そんなことしてて 大丈夫なのか？
と 言われるんです
意味なくね？と
なにそれ 自慢？って言われて
僕は どんどん
ひとりぼっちになっていくんです
自分の好きなことを ひとに喋ることが
できなくなってしまうんです
でも そんな僕を
助けてくれた人たちがいました
その人たちは 本の中の人たちです
僕を助けてくれたのは ライト兄弟だったり
エジソンだったり
彼らも 誰にも信じてもらえない人たちでした
応援も してもらえなかったんです
でも 彼らは 一生懸命がんばったんです
その人たちが 僕を助けてくれました
だから 僕は がんばったんです
自分の好きなことを
もっと 好きになったんです
もっと 伸ばしていったんです
僕は 紙切りが 得意でした
でも それが どんどん発展していって
どんどん 物がつくれるようになって
そして 僕は 自分の会社をつくって
リサイクルのマグネットをつくることが
できるようになったんです
僕は 会社を経営することに
なってしまいました
僕は 生まれて初めて
会社経営したんですが
びっくりするぐらい いきなり大成功です
（笑）
（拍手）
もうね 年商がね
10倍ぐらいに なっちゃったんですよ
それで いい気になって 大失敗です
（笑）
２億円 借金つくりました
自分のせいだと 思いました
全部 自分で なんとかしなきゃと思って
ひとりで 抱え込みました
自分を責めました
そして 日本中 飛び込み営業に歩いたら
ひどい目にばっかり 遭います
だから 飛行機 乗るたんびに
今日こそ この飛行機 落ちてくれって
一生懸命 祈りました
でも 飛行機 落ちませんでした
やがて 僕は成長して
えげつないことも 冷酷なことも
できるようになって
競争相手を やっつけたり
陥れたり できるようになりました
でも その人に どんな家族がいるかなんて
ひとつも考えませんでした
やがて 売り上げが増えていくと
銀行の人が ほめてくれました
でも 僕の心は すっかりおかしくなっていて
誰も 信じることができません
ひとりぼっちなんです
そして なにもかも
合理でしか 考えられないんです
やがては 自分の大切なものも
全部 捨ててしまおうとまで 思ったんです
でも そんなときに僕は
会社が苦しかったもんだから
日本中歩いていて いろんな人に
アドバイスされたんです
それは 青年会議所に 入ったらいいよ って
売り上げにつながるよって 言われました
僕は よこしまな気持ちで
青年会議所に入りました
（笑）
ところが 売り上げには
つながりませんでした
（笑）
でも そこで僕は
かけがえのない 知らなかった人たちと
出逢うチャンスを もらったんです
僕は そこで 友達をつくりました
その友達が 僕を誘ってくれました
児童施設に 僕が ボランティアに
手伝いに行くことに なったんです
ところが 一生懸命 準備して行ってみた
その 児童養護施設の 子どもたちは
親から ひどい目に遭った 子どもたちでした
最初は 誰も 近寄ってきませんでした
でも 一生懸命 かかわっていたら
帰る頃には
帰らないでって 言ってくれました
スキンシップ 求めてくれました
友達と一緒に
やぁ いいことしたよね って
今日 打ち上げ どこでやろうか？なんて
帰ろうと思ったらば
男の子が 自分の夢を 聞かせてくれました
その子の夢は
親と もう一度 暮らすことだそうです
信じられん と思いました
なんで ひどい目に遭わせた 親のことを
まだ 愛してんの？って 思いました
そして なんも いいことできてないわ
と 思いました
だって いくらお金を寄付したとしても
その子を連れて帰って
うちの子にしたとしても
何の解決にも なりません
なぜならば その子は
まだ 親を愛してるからです
なんで こんなことが起きるんだろう？
って 思いました
そして 自分は何のために
ひとをやっつけてまで
金 稼いでんだろうって 思いました
いろんなことが わかんなくなっちゃいました
ぐるんぐるん してしまいました
そしたら 封印した記憶が
よみがえって しまいました
僕は 小学校に上がってすぐに
担任の先生に ものすごい 嫌われたんです
僕が 信じていたことや
ばあちゃんが 教えてくれたことは
全部 否定されました
僕の夢は
お前なんかに できるわけがない って
さんざん 言われました
じいちゃんが なぜてくれた頭は
先生に さんざん 殴られました
とっても つらかったです
でも それを 助けてくれる大人は
いなかったです
僕は その先生が言っていた言葉を
忘れてませんでした
その先生は 「どーせ無理」
という言葉を よく使っていたんです
この 「どーせ無理」 という言葉が
おそろしい言葉なんだなと 思いました
これは 人間の自信と可能性を
奪ってしまう 最悪の言葉です
でも とっても簡単な 言葉なんです
これを 唱えるだけで
何もしなくて 済んでしまうから
とっても 楽チンになれる
おそろしい言葉でも あるんです
こんな言葉で
未来を 諦めさせられてしまった人たちは
自信を失ってしまうんです
でも 人間は 生きてくためには
どうしても 自信が必要なんです
だから 自信を無くしてしまった人の中には
お金で自信を買うようになって
身を飾るようになったり
また それを自慢しなければ
いけなくなったり
そのために ひとを 見下さなければ
いけなくなってしまったり
また 他の人が がんばったら困るから
努力を 邪魔するように
なってしまう人もいるんです
こういう人が みなさんの身のまわりにも
もしかしたら いるかもしれません
でも その人たちは
自信をなくしてしまった
かわいそうな人たち なんです
その人たちが 自分の自信を守りたくって
しょうがなく 他のひとの自信を
奪ってしまってるのかもしれません
さらには 僕の会社に
アフリカの人たちが 来てくれました
彼らが 僕の話を聞いてくれた後で
教えてくれました
今 アフリカでは
自分なんて 勉強したって ムダだぁ
努力したって ムダだぁ って
自分の未来や可能性を
諦めてしまった人たちが
最後には 人を殺して
奪うようになるんだそうです
なぜならば がんばれないから
生み出せないから
奪うしか ないんです
暴力で 奪うこともできます
でも 他にも 嘘をついたり
弱いふりをしたり だましたりして
奪うこともできるんです
でも みんなが奪ってしまったら
社会なんか 成立しないんです
僕は この 「どーせ無理」 という言葉の
おそろしさを 知ることができました
僕は この 「どーせ無理」
人間は 最初から 知らなかったはずだ
いつ 僕たちは こんな言葉を
覚えちゃうんだろうって 考えたんです
それが 宇宙かなって 思ったんです
宇宙は 美しいです
だから 誰もが ちっちゃい頃に
一回は 憧れるんです
でも みなさんは 自分が
宇宙開発できると 思ってますか？
宇宙なんて よっぽど頭が良くないと
すごく お金がかかるって
思い込んでませんか？
国家事業だって 思ってませんか？
誰が それを 教えてくれましたか？
それは こんなことを 教えてくれるのは
やったことがない人 なんです
やったことがない人が
適当な やらない言い訳を
教えてくれるんです
そのせいで 僕たちは
何をしていいのか わからなくなるんです
何ができるのかも
わからなくなってしまうんです
だからこそ 僕は 「どーせ無理」 という
言葉を なくそうと思いました
これがなくなったら いじめや 暴力や
戦争が なくなるかもしれない
児童虐待も なくなるかもしれない
って 思いました
だから 僕は
誰もが 「どーせ無理」 だと思われてる
宇宙開発を してみようと 思ったんです
ところが 僕は
ロケットは危ないから
つくっちゃいけないということを
知っていました
だから 諦めてました
でも 神様がいたんです
神様が 北海道大学の永田教授に
会わせてくれました
永田教授は 奇跡的に
安全なロケット 研究してました
そして 奇跡的に
お金がなくて 諦めようとしていました
僕は お金がないけど
物が つくれるんです
そんなふたりが 出逢っちゃったんです
以来 僕は 人の出逢いには
意味があるんだなと 思うようになりました
神様が あんたとあんた 逢いなさいって
逢わせてくれてるんです
今日 みなさんと逢えてるのも
神様が そろそろ逢っときなって
言ってくれたんだと 思います
僕と 永田先生は 助け合えたんです
なぜならば ふたりとも
足りなかったからなんです
実は 人は 足りないから
助け合うことが できるんです
足りてたら ひとの助けなんか
必要ないじゃないですか
人は 足りないから 助け合えるんです
だからこそ 足りないことを
バカにしちゃ いけないんです
恥ずかしいって 思う必要もないんです
大事なことは
自分は 何やっても
中途半端だなぁ だなんて
自分を責める必要なんか
まったく なかったんです
実は 中途半端っちゅうのは
何もしないよりも 何もできないよりも
全然いいんです
ちょっとできてるだけ マシなんです
だから 自分を責めることなく
足りない自分を マイナスに思う必要なく
一生懸命 できることを
すれば よかったんです
そんな僕たちは 助け合って
今では 宇宙開発が できるようになりました
いろんな研究者が 僕の会社に
実験や研究に 来てくれるように なりました
そして 今では 年に１万人もの子どもたちが
修学旅行や 見学旅行で
僕の会社に 来てくれるように なりました
正直言うと 会社 17人しかいないです
（笑）
ちょっと 大変です
だけども ひとりでも多くの子どもたちが
可能性を 奪われなくなったら いいなぁと
僕は 思っています
僕は 信じてるんです
「どーせ無理」 をなくせば
いい社会が 来ると 思ってます
でも 僕ひとりで できることに
限りがあるから
どうしても 仲間が ほしいんです
これは 僕の代で終わらない
夢なのかも しれないんです
だからこそ みなさんの力を
貸してほしいんです
みなさんが 今日から
「どーせ無理」 っちゅう言葉に
出会ってしまったときに
「だったら こうしてみたら？」 って
言ってくれたら
ただ それだけで いつか
「どーせ無理」 がなくなって
この世から いじめも
虐待も なくなるんです
だから ぜひ みなさんの力を
貸してほしいです
学問というものがあります
僕らは 学問を 一生懸命 学んできました
では 学問っちゅうのは 誰かに 評価される
ためのものだったんでしょうか？
とんでもない 間違いですね
学問っちゅうのは
社会の問題を 解決するために
人類が 生み出したものなんです
必死になって 築き上げたものなんです
じゃぁ 教育って なんでしょうか？
教育っていうのは
失敗の避け方とか 責任の避け方っちゅう
要領いい 生き方を教えるための
ハウツーでしょうか？
全然 違いますね
教育というものは 死に至らない失敗を
安全に 経験させるためのものだったんです
でも それが すっかり
おかしくなってしまったんです
なぜかというと
失敗を マイナスだと思っている大人が
たくさん いたからなんです
その人たちが みんなの可能性と
自信を 奪ってきたんです
でも 大丈夫です
これからの 日本を 良くしていくためには
世界を 良くしていくためには
やったことないことやりたがる人
諦めない人 工夫する人が
増えればいいんです
どーせ無理 に負けない人が
じゃぁ その人たちは
いったい どこにいるのか
それは みんなです
すべての人が そうなんです
なぜならば 僕ら人間は 必ず
小さい頃を 経験するからなんです
みなさんも 思い出してみてください
小さい頃は
ボタンあったら 押してみたかったんです
ハンドルあったら 回してみたかったんです
そして 余計なことすんじゃないって
怒られるもんだったんです
実は 生まれたときから
諦め方を知ってる人間なんて
この世に ひとりもいないんです
みなさんは 全員 諦め方を知らないで
輝いて 生まれてきたんです
でも 僕たちは 諦め方を
ちょっと 習っちゃってるかも しれません
そんな自分たちの 自信を取り戻すための
とてもいい方法が ひとつだけあります
それは やったことがないこと
やってみる なんです
やったことないこと やったら
それだけで ちっこい自信が
わいてきますから
ぜひ みなさんは やったことがないことに
挑んでみてほしいって 思います
でも やったことないことやると
失敗するんです
これは 実験映像です
ロケットが 火吹いて 飛びました
飛びませんでした
火吹いて 落っこっちゃってきました
どうすりゃいいのか？
コントローラーを 捨てて
逃げる
（笑）
今どき こんな 昭和な逃げ方する人
なかなか いないんですけどね
この 実験映像が示していることは
マズイと思ったら 逃げるもアリ
ということなんです
（笑）
（拍手）
そうねぇ 僕が知ってる限り
まじめで 優しくて 責任感のある人ばっかり
死んでしまうんです
死なないでほしいんです
生き延びてほしいんです
だから マズイと思ったら
逃げるのも 絶対アリなんです
でも そのときに
失敗した自分を
逃げた自分を 諦めた自分を
責めないでください
へこまないでください
そんなことする必要ないです
でも こんなとき 自分の心の中は
苦しいとか つらいとか 申し訳ないとか
くやしいとか 悲しいとか 恥ずかしいが
ぐるんぐるんして 大変なことになるんです
でも これが ぐるんぐるんしてる最中は
「ただいま成長中！」
って 言えばいいんです
そしたら ぷりっと ひと皮むけるんです
だから ぜひね 「ただいま成長中！」 って
言ってみてください
そんな僕らは今 生まれて初めての
一回きりの人生を
ぶっつけ本番で 生きてるんです
そんな僕らは
何のために 生まれてきたのか
僕らにとって 失敗というものは
より良くするための
データにすぎませんから
ぶっつけ本番だからね
失敗して 当たり前です
でも 失敗は より良くするための
データだと思って
乗り越えてほしいです
そして 僕たちは
してもらうためや 諦めるために
生まれてきたんじゃないです
そんなことのために
生まれたんじゃないです
僕たちは 世界を救うために 生まれました
世界を救うの 簡単です
世界を構成する すべての人間が
「自分なんて…」 って 思わなくなるだけで
世界は 救われてしまいます
今日から ひとりひとりができる
世界の救い方です
だからぜひ 今日から 救ってください
自分なんて…って 思わないでください
そして これから先
僕らが やってくべきことは
できない理由を 探すことでは ありません
できる理由を 考えることです
ただ それだけで 世界は
きっと あっという間に 良くなるんです
僕の長い話が やっとこ 終わります
僕は 小さい頃から
飛行機 ロケット 好きでした
でも やったことない人は
できるわけないって さんざん言いました
でも 母さんは
「思うは招く」 って 教えてくれました
思い続けたら できるようになりました
だから 思い続けるって きっと 大事です
そして 最後に この ひと言があれば
どんな夢も 叶っちゃうよ って言葉を
プレゼントして 終わりにしたいと 思います
それは
「だったらこうしてみたら？で 夢は叶う」
なんです
考えてみてください
自分の夢を 誰かに 喋ったときに
「いや それ 無理だわ～」
って 言われたら
元気なんか なくなります
でも 「だったらこうしてみたら？
こないだ本屋に こんな本 売ってたよ」
「こないだテレビで こんな番組やってたよ」
って 言われたら
もっと 元気が わくじゃないですか
その方が 絶対 楽しいです
だから お互いに夢を喋って
お互いに 「だったらこうしてみたら？」
って 言ってたら
全員の夢が 叶ってしまいます
全員 有名人に なっちゃいます
素晴らしいですね
だからぜひ この
「だったらこうしてみたら？」 が
世界中で はやったら いいなぁって
そしたら 「どーせ無理」 が
なくなるなと 思ってますので
ぜひみんなで
「だったらこうしてみたら？」 を
はやらせて いきたいと 思います
それがきっと 僕たちが 出逢えた
意味かもしれませんから
お互いに 助け合っていきたいと 思います
ということで 僕も
これからも がんばりますんでね
これからも せっかく 出逢えましたからね
仲良くして ほしいと 思います
今日は ほんとにどうも
ありがとうございました
（拍手）
ありがとうございます